le mentalisme sur Internet c'est bien
mais en vrai c'est mieux je reviens sur
scène avec mon nouveau spectacle qui
mélange comme toujours humour mentalisme
et science je joue à Paris au Palais des
Glaces pour seulement 18 représentations
puis le spectacle fera sa première
tournée avec des dates en France
Belgique Suisse jusqu'en juin 2h de show
et ça va être un délire je comprends pas
les gens qui disent que j'ai un balai
dans le cul c'est le temps passe comme
tu dis je peux dire au vieux tu imagines
les matières grises ont fait ça ensemble
depuis 2019 regarde ce qu'on est devenu
et tu as perdu des dents mais ça va moi
j'ai perdu de la couleur sur ma barbe tu
as perdu du poids beaucoup bah moi j'en
ai pris un petit peu c'est le maillot tu
es plus aussi stable qu'avant j'ai peur
qu'il me tombe dessus
on va en parler tu te calmes oui
Mesdames et Messieurs les abonnés de la
chaîne bienvenue dans cette vidéo
Mesdames et Messieurs les non abonnés de
cette chaîne abonnez-vous à cette chaîne
c'est vraiment un clic sur un bouton ça
va vous prendre deux secondes on va
parler aujourd'hui de ce matière grise
précisément parce que ce matière grise
va être un bouquet final de plusieurs
matières grises et ça va être la fin de
ce format
[Musique]
Loïc c'est la fin de ce format on a
lancé ce format là en 2019 on devait
faire une seule vidéo on en a fait quoi
18 du coup des matières grassuin on
devait en faire qu'un et à la base à la
base c'était parce que le premier
épisode est un partenariat à l'époque
avec une marque de téléphonie nous avait
permis de financer ce premier et après
on a tout auto-financé avec les fameux
les sponsorias ça a été le truc le plus
apprécié de matière grise en fait
alors pourquoi on arrête ce format
surtout que j'ai annoncé récemment qu'on
avait aussi arrêté les cabinets
curieuses
parce que les formats doivent avoir une
fin un moment donné il faut que ça nous
excite il faut qu'il y ait de la
nouveauté faut que ça vous excite aussi
la nouveauté on le voit aussi il y a une
petite chute de vue sur matière grise
c'est normal en fait parce que ça fait
trois ans que ça existe et on a des
idées qu'on a pas le temps de mettre en
place parce que on a ces formes là à
sortir le bouquet final c'est pas avec
un invité c'est avec trois invités avec
différentes expériences qui viennent de
différents domaines et pas de sujets
déjà défini et donc avec une petite
surprise à la fin de cette vidéo alors
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue dans ce
dernier épisode de matière grise
[Musique]
la première expérience elle va se passer
avec Morgane vs on a tourné cette
expérience en septembre 2021 ce que
Morgan s'en souvient encore l'idée
c'était de se dire c'est quoi le rapport
de notre cerveau vis-à-vis de l'argent
c'était intéressant de voir les
expériences qu'il y avait derrière il y
en a une particulière qui nous a plu
c'est celle que vous allez voir
maintenant c'est le fait que notre
cerveau un tel rapport perverti à la
notion de richesse et du pouvoir qui va
derrière qu'il est capable de développer
des capacités pour le corps en fonction
de l'argent qu'il manipule
c'est pas bien clair bah regardez
l'expérience
[Musique]
Morgane on a de l'eau ici on va vite
rentrer dans le vif du sujet ok on va
comparer laquelle est la meilleure voilà
ok pas de souci je suis chaud en réalité
tu vas retrousser ta manche et on va
plonger la main dans l'eau et on va
tenir autant de temps que possible
évidemment l'eau est particulièrement
chaude l'idée c'est pas de te brûler
quand ça t'es trop désagréable tu
retiens la main de l'autre tout
simplement et je vais chronométrer
combien de temps tu tiens tu me dis 3 2
oh [ __ ] c'est pas là on fait moyen à
la 3 secondes 50
faible tu veux laisser les deux mains là
je reste minimum ok c'est parti 3 2 1
ok 3 23 je le note pour plus tard on
fera une comparaison on va faire quelque
chose de plus fun pour l'instant est-ce
qu'on peut retirer les bassines s'il
vous plaît ça va ça va tu as pas trouvé
ça va c'était très cool comme concept
merci de m'avoir invité est-ce qu'on
peut faire venir le prochain invité
celui qui est sympa s'il vous plaît me
rejoint bah écoute 3 23 ouais j'aurais
pas pu faire mieux non mais ça brûle
c'est pas une douleur ou tu peux
résister la brûlure la bouche elle
brûlure en fait on a mis la température
de l'eau juste assez pour qui on ait un
moment désagréable mais pas trop fort
pour que tu puisses tenir et savoir
quand l'enlever le but était pas
traumatiser la peau des invités quand
même t'inquiète pas on va faire un truc
beaucoup plus cool ok ok on va prendre
du biff maintenant et on va discuter de
ta chaîne l'idée c'est qu'on discute
pendant ce qu'on discute tu me fais des
tas comme ça ok ok et à tous les tas de
on va dire de de 10 billets tu me fais
une petite coche tu vois on va dire les
billets de 100 les billets de 50 les
billets de 20 et à chaque fois que tu as
fini un top 10 tu te mets de côté tu
fais une petite coche comme ça
directement les concepts vs directement
comme j'ai pas d'INSPIRE j'étais prendre
un concept américain c'était beaucoup
plus simple c'est vrai c'est à cause que
tu avais vu que dans un mec qui a voulu
des États-Unis mais écoute m'en gagne un
truc qui cartonne si ça te tente tu me
dis et on le fait avec toi et je le fais
mais en fait ce qui est incroyable c'est
qu'il est infini ton concept ouais mais
je commence un pote
j'essaie de partir un petit peu à
l'étranger mais j'essaie de bouger un
petit peu plus même si pour moi en
France on a la meilleure gastronomie
donc ça ne me dérange pas trop si si on
te disait tiens là demain tu peux faire
le concept que tu veux mais c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas un vs malgré le fait
que ta peine Morgan vs tu fais quoi
je fais quoi je ferai un truc à la
jacasse tu vois
et tout et je rêve de faire un truc un
peu la Michaël Youn parce qu'il a fait
pendant les 11 commandements mais je
rêve de faire ça toi tu fais pas du coup
je le ferai plus tard ok ok
dans ce que je fais actuellement je le
ferai un jour trop bien la chaîne elle a
combien d'Abos maintenant je sais qu'on
compte pas une chaîne en abo mais c'est
quand même 258000 c'est une espèce
d'envolée dès que tu as sorti le truc ça
fait rire c'est trop cool bah tu sais
c'est l'argent les Français comme tu
l'as dit en déclic un peu d'argent dans
le titre j'ai vraiment l'impression du
mec qui est venu et il a demandé un
cachet et du coup avant avant de tourner
il vérifie juste un peu quelconque
jusqu'ici tout va bien
exactement en fait c'est des faux
billets qu'on a loué et du coup on doit
les rendre on voulait juste vérifier si
au bout de jour de tournage vous n'avez
pas perdu alors je pense que moi je
compte toujours deux fois la chante une
fois pour pas que la vidéo soit longue
donc en fait tu le mets tu ne m'aides
pas si tu as raison donne-moi un petit
paquet
je compte pour rien exactement j'adore
ta chaîne en vrai je suis hein c'est pas
du tout je vais aller mais écoute pour
l'instant tu me fais faire des petits
jeux j'aime bien tu vas remettre ta main
dedans et tenir autant de temps que tu
peux et on va comparer Morgane vs avec
Morgan DS en vrai là je vois pas
pourquoi ça va changer
ça me brûle même plus
c'est
bon j'ai passé le déclic ou tu sais je
peux maintenant je vois plus mal je peux
rester à enlever ta main alors du coup
merci à neuf c'est à trois fois plus ou
tu as fait à 6 ça fait mal mais
maintenant je peux tenir rince là quand
même parce que c'est la même chaleur
donc on va éviter de toujours à deux
c'est bon après c'est bon quoi c'est la
même température quand on est riche on a
moins mal c'est ouf c'est c'est
incroyable ça vaut le coup ça vaut le
coup c'est abdelier en fait il y a c'est
on a reproduit une étude qui a été faite
il y a quelques années sur des centaines
de personnes alors c'était une étude
d'un double aveugle on mettait des gens
dans des salles il y en a qui comptaient
des billets blancs des bouts de papier
et deux petits côtés des vrais bifs
comme ça d'accord autant de temps que
nous et après on les mettait dans une
main à température
identique et tout ce qu'on comptait de
la thune pendant plus de 5 minutes
tiennent plus longtemps parce que le
fait de manipuler l'argent l'argent un
pouvoir sur notre cerveau qui joue sur
notre confiance en nous et sur notre
confiance en nous et aussi notre
altruisme parce que en réalité on s'est
aperçu que ces personnes avaient un
autre test quand elles partaient de la
salle elle croisait quelqu'un qui était
payée pour faire ça qu'il est bousculent
un peu qu'il faisait tomber des papiers
toutes les personnes qu'on comptait des
billets blancs ont aidé à ramasser les
papiers toutes les personnes qui avaient
compté des billets ont fait pardon et ne
l'ont pas aidé c'est incroyable et le
truc pour le vivre pour le croire de
juste le fait de toucher de l'argent
même quand c'est de la représentation de
l'argent de le toucher de manipuler en
fait c'est que je dis bien mon cerveau
que c'est du faux il le sait mais dans
la case argent dans le fond tu es quand
même en train de compter du biff il sait
ce que c'est de noter du biff et tout ça
et le fait de le noter en plus je suis
sûr que ça a rajouté un truc
psychologiquement de ok on fait les
comptes du magot quoi tu vois c'était
mon premier taf en restauration les fins
de caisse et tous les soirs faire ça et
en vrai ça les scores ils sont tellement
haut que ça ne peut pas ne pas marcher
donc en fait je l'ai même pas testé moi
à l'avance chez moi mais attention
n'importe quelle douleur c'est à dire
que si j'ai une épreuve dans ma vie où
je sais que je vais avoir mal c'est
marrant c'est un exemple un tatouage
merci une prise de sang et tout je peux
manipuler avec la TuneIn c'est fou non
c'est fou cette expérience c'est un
délire
merci beaucoup à Morgane vs d'avoir
participé à cette expérience vous
retrouverez bien sur un lien vers sa
chaîne dans la description d'ailleurs sa
chaîne est-elle mieux que la chaîne du
prochain invité vous avez des questions
qui se posent Morgan il fait des versus
non les deux chaînes sont très bien le
prochain invité c'est Léonard ou avec
lui on voulait explorer un petit peu le
rapport de notre cerveau face au hasard
et pour mettre ça un petit peu en valeur
en fait pour mettre une histoire autour
de ça je lui avais fait tout un principe
de tour de magie parce que pour moi il y
a pas plus hasardeux qu'un jeu de 52
cartes d'ailleurs fun fact le
saviez-vous si vous mélangez maintenant
un jeu de 50 de cartes il y a de fortes
chances que le mélange que vous allez
obtenir n'est jamais existé dans toute
l'histoire de l'humanité tellement il y
a de possibilités de mélange possible
c'est exponentiel bref vous allez voir
ce tour là avec Léonard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va parler de synchronicité la
synchronicité c'est un hasard
remarquable pour symboliser ce qu'est la
synchronicité le hasard remarquable je
me suis dit on va prendre un jeu de
cartes ça c'est un bon hasard un bon
hasard par exemple ce serait je prends
une carte et tu prends une carte et
peut-être elles ont un truc entre elles
regardent prendre une carte tu l'as
vendues
juste devant toi et puis moi j'en prends
une prends celle-ci tu vois j'aurais pu
prendre elle mais je sais pas je le sens
ici tu vois on retourne aux cartes à 3 1
2 3 je te la montre moi
ça pour le coup c'est pas encore le tour
le tour il a pas commencé le tour a pas
commencé
c'est un bon hasard on appelle ça des
cartes jumelles
on va voir si on peut provoquer ce genre
de hasard encore un peu plus fort mais
c'est fou c'est toi tu as fait exprès
et après on va sortir mais trois cartes
préférées je te raconterai leur histoire
il fait du card district
je vais te sortir mes trois cartes
préférées à savoir l'as de trèfle
[Musique]
pas du tout ah si bravo le 6 de carreaux
voici et le 7 de trèfle ça c'était trois
cartes préférées trois cartes préférées
alors pourquoi parce que l'as de trèfle
ça représente l'argent parce que mes
parents et toute ma vie j'habitais au 6
rue je ne dirais pas où par contre
à côté de La Rochelle OK et le 7 parce
que le 7 c'est un chiffre magique les
sept merveilles du monde ce que je vais
te demander c'est de distribuer les
cartes comme ça sous les trucs mettez
pas obligé de d'être régulier tu peux en
mettre deux ici une là etc jusqu'à temps
que tu aies plus de cartes ok moi je ne
toucherai plus à rien à partir de
maintenant
tu peux faire un tas tu es pas obligé je
peux en mettre tout d'un côté bah ouais
malheureusement oui
on dirait le gars quand tu lui fais un
tour qui est chiant et c'est comme un
chifoumi absolument casser ton tour non
mais tout derrière c'est on teste le
hasard c'est pas c'est pas un vrai tour
tu peux même poser des paquets
directement ok
comme ça quoi maintenant tu vas refermer
pour avoir trois paquets bien propres en
face de chacune de mes cartes préférées
tu as pas de carte préférée
et tu vas mettre chacune de mes cartes
sur chacun des paquets formidable parfum
direct a fait ça toute ta vie
voilà et on va terminer de la manière
suivante tu vas faire des coupes
complètes sur chaque paquet autant de
fois que tu veux est-ce que tu sais ce
que c'est une coupe complet et tu
complètes ok tu complètes avec tout le
paquet donc c'est fait là ouais mais tu
peux tu peux le refaire si tu veux
couper un autre endroit
voilà
et là
c'est pas mal nickel plus que deux
étapes tu vas me réunir tout ça en un
seul paquet dans l'ordre que tu veux
c'est pour ça que je te laisse faire toi
je sais qu'à chaque fois il influence
donc pas du tout mais c'est le hasard
est-ce que tu veux couper une dernière
fois ou pas c'est toi qui décide
ouais ok
comme tu veux
ok le hasard remarquable la
synchronicité fait que attention miracle
mes trois cartes préférées sont face en
l'air c'est bluffé alors pas du tout je
crois que c'est évident c'est vrai je
pensais qu'avec le temps tu aurais
oublié qu'elles étaient en l'air dès le
départ pas du tout non par contre ce qui
est intéressant c'est que malgré tout ce
que tu as fait on peut regarder quelles
sont les cartes qui se sont mises juste
à côté de mes cartes préférées
et et au tout début tu as pris une carte
au hasard au hasard et c'est marrant
c'était des cartes Gmail c'était une
belle synchronicité la carte jumelle de
l'Est de trèfle c'est quoi d'après toi
du coup c'est une carte noire
là tu vois si je l'ai retendre comme ça
pour se dire que j'ai manipulé quelque
chose tu vois alors que pas du tout
c'est vrai vraiment c'est toi qui a fait
ça est-ce que tu peux retourner les deux
autres s'il te plaît
non non
mais comment tu as fait si la probable
est impossible que la solstice de cœur
insupportable quand on fait un super
tour et que tu comprends pas
merci à Léonard d'avoir participé à
cette expérience là vous retrouverez un
lien vers sa chaîne dans la description
et avant de passer à la troisième et
dernière expérience de ce bouquet final
ça passait une vitesse Loïc c'est
incroyable je ne vois pas le temps je ne
vois pas je ne te vois pas je me suis
fait opérer des yeux et je ne te vois
plus du tout et en réalité avant de
passer à la dernière expérience avec
Manon brille on va vous faire un petit
florilège des c'est à vous de florilège
là a été composé sous la forme d'un pot
pourri par Loïc oui
c'est à vous
[Musique]
nous avons six pièces de monnaie je vais
te demander de faire deux lignes de
quatre pièces avec ces 6 pièces deux
lignes de 4 pièces avec ces 6 pièces
[Musique]
deux lignes de ligne de 4 pièces
2 lignes de 4 pièces avec ces 6 et moins
de malins Morgan vs c'est pas l'habitude
de manipuler des pièces les billets je
te fais des lignes quand tu veux mais là
c'est très content
il y a vraiment pas le temps de vraiment
là
Kathleen de deux pièces deux lignes de 4
pièces deux lignes de 4 pièces
en plus parce que tu vas me faire un
truc et je vais faire mais oui c'est
logique mais là comme ça je n'en sais
rien
là je n'ai pas les capacités 1 2
3 4
c'est une ligne comme ça
si ça c'est une ligne sinon
ouais mais alors c'est une commande en
vrai c'est pas con d'avoir fait ça je
trouve mais dans ces cas-là tu aurais
effectivement une ligne de 4 pièces
moi je trouve ça tient mais là tu aurais
une ligne de une deux trois quatre cinq
six pièces c'est un peu dommage avec
l'installent que tu as à voir que si
balles à table comme ça un peu un peu
limite je sais pas en vrai là
déjà tu peux commencer à réfléchir à
comment faire deux lignes de trois
pièces là tu as deux lignes de 3 pièces
ouais exactement comment tu peux faire
pour avoir des lignes de 4 pièces en
reprenant ton idée de colonne
absolument ah [ __ ] ça par contre ça
c'est mon dada je kiffe ce genre de base
et ça aussi ça fonctionne dans notre
rapport à l'argent de on peut avoir de
l'argent qui sert à plusieurs choses à
plusieurs pôles en même temps à
plusieurs endroits on peut investir pour
récupérer avoir des actifs des passifs
je trouve que ça symbolise bien ça de
t'es pas obligé de toujours tout séparer
tu peux aussi se faire croiser des
choses et penser différemment en fait
dans son rapport à l'argent c'était un
message philosophique ou alors c'était
juste une énigme message philosophique
ok ça me fait plaisir [ __ ] c'est fou
ok ça j'aime bien dis toi qu'il y a un
parieur qui est sur un marché au bord
d'un mètre c'est un mec qui fait des
jeux d'argent au bord d'un lac sur un
marché j'ai l'impression que tu me
racontes une histoire comme quand
j'étais petit
il propose un jeu qui est très simple il
a un sac et dans ce sac il y a deux
cailloux à l'intérieur il y a un des
deux cailloux qui a une croix rouge qui
est destinée dessus et l'autre qu'on a
pas ok ok le jeu il est très simple il
faut parier 10 euros et piocher au
hasard un caillou et si c'est le caillou
avec la croix tu as gagné s'il y a pas
de croix dessus tu as perdu tes 10 euros
très simple comme jeu extrêmement simple
par contre nous on sait un truc c'est
que c'est un escroc c'est à dire qu'il y
a pas de cailloux avec la Croix-Rouge
d'accord de cailloux avec une d'accord
avec pas de croix dessus comment tu peux
aller le voir jouer contre lui et gagner
quand même c'est à dire que tu sais que
dans son sac donc là il y a le lac il y
a le but devant il y a le marché il a
son petit sac avec les deux cailloux
dedans toi tu dois être capable de
parier 10 euros et de gagner alors que
toi et moi on sait que dans les deux
cailloux qui a dans le sac il y en a pas
il y a une croix rouge évidemment je lui
dis au lieu je lui dis que au lieu de
prendre le caillot avec la Croix Rouge
je prends le caillou avec enfin le
caillou sans croix rouge et tu vas te
dire ben non c'est pas les règles de mon
jeu ok je prends un caillou
et je dessine une croix rouge très
rapidement dessus il risque de le voir
comment je peux obligatoirement gagner
de l'argent lui vole 10 euros
tu peux l'obliger à dire que tu as gagné
ah ok je sais je lui dis de montrer sa
main en premier OK et comme ça si lui il
a pas son quai enfin il est si lui dans
sa main il a celle où il y a pas de
croix forcément dans la mienne c'est que
il y a la croix ça se tient complètement
ça pourrait être la solution la solution
attendue mais la tienne elle fonctionne
très bien c'est tu choisis un caillou tu
le jettes dans le lac et tu dis vas-y
fais voir l'autre s'il y a pas de croix
dessus c'est que j'aime bien le jeter
celui avec la croix mais ça marche
pareil tu vois ce que je veux dire bravo
tu l'obliges à faire voir l'autre
caillou à ta place
félicitations les États-Unis d'Amérique
ont un plan officiel en cas d'apocalypse
zombie bah je dis oui juste parce que
j'ai envie que ça soit vrai par contre
c'est complètement vrai et ça s'appelle
le
complimente
l'huile durant la cuisson permet au
pattes de ne pas coller c'est faux c'est
faux tu sais que c'est faux tu crois que
c'est faux
je sais que c'est faux j'ai peur parce
que une doctorante en shopping
et ça ça fait partie des petites astuces
tellement faciles à se transmettre et
tellement facile à réaliser que je te
paille dans 10 générations on continuera
à dire mais un peu d'huile pour pas que
ça colle s'échapper d'une prison au
Mexique c'est légal
alors je ne sais pas mais du vu que tu
poses la question j'ai envie de dire oui
sinon tu la poserais pas
en fait c'est pas parce que il considère
que c'est dans la nature humaine de pas
vouloir être enfermé ok ce qui peut être
illégal c'est de frapper quelqu'un par
exemple mais oui alors du coup ils se
disent c'est normal que l'humain a envie
de s'échapper ISO ok il a réussi c'est
bon
en tout cas c'est pas une légale c'est
complètement fou Einstein a échoué un
examen de maths et je sais que on
exagère en disant Einstein était nul en
maths nanana que c'est pas vrai qu'il
était genre
moyen mais pas nul non c'est toujours
été plutôt bon on a toujours été très
bon en masse la seule chose qu'il a raté
c'est un examen d'entrer dans une école
j'étais pas du tout un examen de maths
et ça c'est juste très rassurant de se
dire ça en fait et du coup pareil plus
on le dira plus on croit que c'est vrai
parce que c'est quand même sexy de se
dire et le génie qui était nul
merci merci beaucoup à c'est à vous
d'avoir participé à cette émission vous
vous retrouverez le mot c'est à vous
dans la description j'ai pas mieux cette
troisième expérience c'est un peu plus
calme c'est un peu plus posé on est un
peu plus en mode discussion presque un
podcast avec Manon brille où on parle de
l'effet de Nick Kruger si vous savez pas
vous allez bientôt découvrir ce que
c'est donc c'est voilà c'est plus chill
ecoutez ça tranquillement c'est assez
intéressant même moi ça m'a stimulé
cérébralement cette discussion et on a
fait un truc en plus mais ça je vous en
parle après
[Musique]
c'est moi on connaît quelque chose nous
on a l'impression de le connaître et
d'en parler avec force confiance et
limite on est virulent des fois quand on
doit défendre ce sujet là ça marche donc
c'est l'effet de Nick Kruger l'ultra
crépitarianisme c'est pareil c'est la
même chose mais en plus compliqué et
donc plus tu connais un mot compliqué
déjà plus on a l'impression que tu sais
quelque chose tu vas je te fais voir la
courbe de l'effet d'anine Kruger qui est
très intéressant
merci on me l'a déjà dit ça c'est la
force de la confiance et ça c'est ton
degré de compétence sur un sujet au tout
début tu es pas très compétent et du
coup tu es extrêmement confiant quand tu
vas en parler en fait est-ce que tu
autosé ta propre expertise et comme tu
sais déjà pas grand-chose c'est
l'impression du coup de tout savoir en
général si tu es vraiment intéressé par
le sujet tu vas continuer à le creuser
et donc tu vas augmenter ta compétence
et ça va te faire tomber très très bas
en terme de confiance c'est là que tu
atteint la vallée de l'humilité et je
rencontre que
je pense que toi tu as déjà eu ça
sûrement sur des sujets que tu traites
soit dans tes études soit dans tes
vidéos ou un moment tu dis waouh attends
c'est bien plus complexe que ça attends
conscience de l'ampleur des paramètres à
intégrer un peu plus que juste le fait
que tu avais checké au début on va dire
c'est ça et du coup la vallée de
l'humidité c'est ça va de perdre avec le
fait de d'avoir vu tout ce que tu sais
pas est de comprendre ça et après il y a
une espèce de montée l'effet de microger
il s'applique dès que tu parles de
l'effet de Nick regarde que moi je suis
là quand je parle de l'effet de Nick
regarde parce que dans le fond est-ce
que j'ai été creusé très loin que tu te
demandes si la personne qui te parle
d'un sujet à là on est là en général
quoi te répondait oui ou des noms et
quelle cloque la question très
rapidement il y a quand même de fortes
chances qu'elle soit là alors que si on
en est ici ou ici on va dire
ça dépend je vais t'expliquer pourquoi
et c'est tout de suite un peu plus long
c'est un signe de maîtrise prenons un
exemple très concret toi tu as enseigné
ou pas du tout tu es enseigné primaire
en primaire et un petit peu pendant ma
thèse j'ai donné des cours d'histoire en
licence tu juges comment ta qualité à
enseigner est-ce que tu trouves que tu
étais bonne enseignante une très
mauvaise une je pense dans la moyenne et
surtout mon expérience elle est assez
courte donc j'ai été jeune prof surtout
et c'est quand même un truc qui
s'acquiert sur le long terme de
perfectionner ta méthode parce que
l'expérience tout simplement donc comme
moi j'ai enseigné pas très longtemps je
pense que je suis quand même plutôt
débutante
qui pense à avoir une représentation du
week-end prof et qui font rire et
comment ça se fait que vous avez pas
fait ça vous inquiétez pas c'est normal
il y a l'incapacité à s'auto-évaluer
c'est quand même très très dur cette
question elle a été posée à quelques
milliers d'enseignants 68% des
professeurs se considèrent comme faisant
partie des plus performants
et 90% d'entre eux se considèrent au
moins bien au-dessus de la moyenne ok tu
vois 90% de la moyenne c'est que soit la
moyenne qui est pas bonne soit eux qui
se surévaluent c'est très très dur de
s'auto-évaluer et tu vois même en fait
que dans l'auto-évaluation il y a
vraiment deux gros pics c'est la
surévaluation et la sous-évaluation
qu'est-ce que c'est pas juste savoir ton
sujet c'est réussir à transmettre
surtout faudrait demander aux élèves en
vrai je peux demander à mes élèves
c'était les la première génération que
j'ai eu c'était des CM2 et c'était les
2000 donc les 2000 ils ont un petit peu
21 ans maintenant parce que ça veut dire
qu'il
y a des voitures s'il y a des élèves de
Manon
imagine que tu passes une maîtrise là en
psycho et tu obtiens une maîtrise tu
sais que on dit plus maîtrise depuis
bien longtemps Fabien
t'adapter une énigme américaine
dans laquelle je vais chercher cette
année et américaine imagine tu es une
américaine et tu vis dans le passé
et je fais une maîtrise et j'ai eu à en
psychotadies
comment tu te sens dans cette
connaissance ensuite d'après toi comment
tu te sentirais dans cette situation
face à cette connaissance écoute je me
permets enfin je l'ai vécu pour mon
Master story j'ai une bonne note bon moi
quand même ça m'avait ça m'avait apporté
de la reconnaissance et de la validation
qui m'avait aussi conforté pour aller en
tête il y a la note à un moment donné il
y a les spécialistes qui l'ont évalué
donc c'est quoi je la prends
ça sert aussi à valider un état de
connaissance à un moment donné et après
c'est quoi que tu as dit que tu as fait
j'ai fait un master d'histoire et
ensuite une thèse du coup est-ce que tu
as vécu ce côté en fait je sais rien
ouais ok
de niveau de recherche de responsabilité
tu es tu deviens un collègue aussi des
autres chercheurs donc toi aussi tu
produis de la recherche pour ton labo
qui va servir et tout donc tu as une
responsabilité haute que pour ma sœur
qui est déjà un travail de recherche
bien sûr mais du coup tu es ont été
publié comme les autres et tout donc tu
as une un truc de mais moi je suis à
côté de ces chercheurs qui sont là
depuis 1000 ans et tu te sens vraiment
tout petit quoi et c'est normal au début
d'ailleurs parce qu'en effet tu défriche
à peine le sujet donc c'est trop cool
parce que c'est la vraie bonne
représentation entre croire et savoir
c'est à dire que au moment où tu as eu
ton master tu dis ok on m'a validé un
truc et je sais que je sais des choses
et c'est vrai tu vois et en même temps
je pense que moi si j'avais été à ta
place j'aurais cru même que j'avais
quand même fait pas mal le tour de la
question et du coup après tu arrives à
la suite et là tu as l'impression de de
rien savoir par rapport à ce qui reste
mais en fait ça c'est une croyance parce
que par contre en vrai tu en sais des
choses c'est juste tu connais que les
pièces d'un puzzle et c'est vrai que le
puzzle est beaucoup plus grand en fait
au final
c'était un tableau un peu général du
sujet et après en thèse on est allé
creuser un truc en particulier et tu dis
bah c'est très précis ça va jamais être
aussi long que ça et en fait si parce
que
je dis ah en fait je sais rien enfin si
tu as quand même tes acquis d'avant par
rapport à ce que tu vas sortir de la
tête ils sont bien en dessous clairement
nouvelle question
à laquelle la réponse sera que oui ou
non as-tu une opinion politique oui
est-ce que tu as un candidat de
prédilection
et est-ce que tu as repéré des candidats
qui pourraient potentiellement devenir
des candidats préférés oui et est-ce que
tu serais concrètement capable de donner
cinq mesures pour chacun de ces
candidats
non en fait
il y en a qui nous regardent et qui
disent ben moi c'est sûr j'ai déjà un
candidat préféré et peut-être qu'il sait
même pas encore présenté qui c'est déjà
leur candidat préféré et te dire ok pour
vérifier que c'est vraiment ton candidat
préféré à cause de ces de ces mesures et
de son programme comme souvent tu peux
le prédor dans conversation d'engueulade
entre amis entre famille tu te dis juste
est-ce que je connais 10 points de son
programme on est lié assez rarement un
programme on élit
des hommes plus des sensations une
couleur après des fois des idées quand
même et la
personnalités là mais il a été démontré
que ça a joué énormément malheureusement
il y a des études intéressantes aussi
qui montent le billet de conformité et
qui montre que du coup la présence
médiatique de telle ou telle personne et
ce que vont dire les sondages va va
influencer énormément le résultat
ça ça a été démontré plein de fois et
puis le charisme de la personne encore
plus que son on se dit non enfin moi en
tout cas j'essaye de réfléchir à voter
pour un programme et tout cela dit ça
peut ça a pu m'arriver qui est une
personnalité qui m'énerve tellement que
j'ai plus envie de voter pour alors que
je suis plutôt d'accord avec les idées
ça c'est arrivé aussi dans ce sens là
on pense savoir pourquoi on vote mais en
fait bon on se retrouve mais
vraiment on tourne ça avant les
élections présidentielles que nous
venons de vivre donc avant le début de
campagne on tourne ça on est en 2012 on
a une avance sur cette chaîne c'est un
délire c'est trop cool
merci beaucoup à Manon brille d'avoir
participé à cette expérience et à ce
matière grise vous trouverez un lien
vers sa chaîne dans la description
n'hésitez pas à aller voir ce qu'elle
fait j'aime beaucoup on avait le jour
même essayé de faire autre chose et là
c'est un petit peu long c'est posé la
question avec Loïc on en fait quoi de ça
en gros suite à cette discussion sur le
fait de Nick Kruger on s'était dit avec
Manon qu'est-ce que ça donne si on doit
nous défendre un sujet qu'on connaît pas
du tout est-ce que on arrive à s'auto
convaincre qu'on le connaît est-ce qu'on
ment un petit peu est-ce qu'on parle
avec BMS on a essayé de le faire et
après il y a des gens qui nous posent
des questions et nous on rebondit dessus
et ensuite on a une spécialiste du sujet
qui vient nous débunker donc on vous le
met dans la description c'est une vidéo
non répertoriée comme ça vous pouvez
décider de prendre le temps de le
regarder ou pas merci beaucoup d'avoir
suivi ces 18 je crois épisode de matière
grise depuis
2019 n'ayez pas peur si vous étiez fan
de ce format on a autre chose qui arrive
mais qui est dans le même ADN de toute
manière tout ce que je fais fais partie
du même ADN on va se renouveler on va on
va aussi re stimuler en faisant autre
chose et ça devrait aussi vous
restimuler merci beaucoup à toutes les
personnes qui ont participé à ces
matières grises les tous les invités en
fait que qu'il y a eu plus d'une
vingtaine en fait au final avec ce
bouquet final là merci à toutes les
équipes qui ont travaillé dessus sur les
anciens sur les derniers merci à
updated qui a permis à la saison 2 aussi
d'exister merci à vous de suivre cette
chaîne pensez vraiment à vous abonner
pensez à activer la cloche pour voir les
notifications pensez à passer sur
Youtube de temps en temps il y a pas que
Tik Tok dans la vie les gars mais après
si vous êtes sur Tik Tok moi j'ai un Tik
Tok alors voilà quoi je m'appelle
toujours Fabien olicard
ciao mais en fait on les laisse avec le
feu
exact et Loïc et moi nous voulons du
coup avec mais toi tu as envie de
rajouter du travail de montage en fait
c'est ça le truc non
mais c'est la vie c'est trop bien on
vous laisse avec le florilège des
sponsorias des fois ça parle de
spectacle je suis en spectacle de même
pour un spectacle on se fera un
sponsorial en live prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt
non parce que je me demandais ça Ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Fabien olicard le fabien olicard est un
artiste pluridisciplinaire passionné par
le cerveau le mental mais aussi l'humour
il peut s'exprimer de différentes
manières équipées de la technologie five
finger il peut écrire des livres comme
dernièrement votre temps est infini il y
a dans la description Fabien licard un
artiste qu'on aimerait bien lire son
livre et voir son spectacle
ça a pas l'air d'aller ça va pas du tout
j'ai une diarrhée mentale j'arrête pas
de dire de la merde mais tu ne connais
pas Fabien olicard non qu'est-ce que
c'est attends ne bouge pas
Fabien olicard c'est avant tout un
spectacle mêlant humour et mentalisme et
ses riches en menthe à l'eau-éléments et
les en tournée dans toute la France où
est-ce que je peux le prendre à emporter
oh non un Fabien olicard ça se garde ces
personnel
[Rires]
si tu veux réfléchir mieux et plus vite
et divertir ton esprit en apprenant tout
en rigolant et baisse c'est possible et
c'est maintenant ici avec Fabien olicard
avec son spectacle d'humour et de
mentalisme dans toute la France en
tournée mais même aussi en Belgique en
Suisse et surtout au Zénith de Paris le
20 novembre tu vas avoir les neurones
ils vont péter comme des pop-corns parce
que tu as beaucoup rigolé et surtout tu
vas avoir des mentalisme et ça c'est
bluffant et même toi peut-être tu vas te
bluffer utilise Fabien olicard c'est du
mentalisme à l'état pur et sans
spectacle quand on est dans toute la
France mais surtout au Zénith de Paris
le 20 novembre ça va être incroyable
pour toi parce que toutes les
informations sont dans la description
je suis obligé d'attendre que tu parles
pour traduire sinon on va voir que je
traduis de la merde in the description
dans la description
traduit bien là je l'ai fait en français
ça peut enfin c'est bien
mon gars là je vais faire plein de trucs
aujourd'hui
je peux te dire que là je vais tout
dépouiller j'ai des idées surtout
comment tu fais tu as vu ce que tu
manges regarde fais gaffe parce que tu
manges moi je mange du Furious du
curious à tous mes petits déjeuners
c'est 52 pages tu as de tout cette
stimule le cerveau des dossiers un petit
peu sur tout sur n'importe quoi c'est
très très bon pour tes neurones ça et ça
c'est dans tous les paquets de céréales
je peux je prends et j'ai les curieuses
vaut mieux que tu passes par le site qui
est dans la description quand même ça
fait plaisir ça ah je me sens tu vois
c'est parti
moi je vais bien
il existe un homme qui peut vous
apprendre à gouverner l'univers là c'est
peut-être un petit peu beaucoup il
existe un homme qui peut faire un
chifoumi en projection astrale un homme
qui a traversé les dimensions pour vous
livrer ses plus grands secrets de
manipulation alors moi j'ai surtout
traversé le périph pour venir au
tournage
qui n'a pas compris qu'on essayait de
faire la promotion du bouquin du livre
ah du coup cette tu parlais de mon
nouveau livre oui tout à fait ah mais
non j'avais pas compris mais du coup
c'est ton avis sincère sur mon lit
le plus sincère non mais ça me touche
beaucoup donc loïc a raison j'ai sorti
mon cinquième livre qui s'appelle
l'antigut de la manipulation le
[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
la mystérieuse disparition de Fabien
sottiflart où est-il que fait-il
pourquoi n'est-il pas présent pour cette
partie partenariat c'est ce que nous
allons découvrir aujourd'hui bienvenue
dans cabinet partenariat
alors ben on va commencer par la phase
d'exploration ah et on voit bah on voit
quoi on voit qu'il est en tournée et oui
à peine de singularité fini qu'il est
déjà reparti en tournée dans toute la
France et casse-tête résolu
donc si vous voulez le voir en spectacle
je vous mets juste là la liste de la
tournée vous avez un doute vous allez
sur Fabien olicard.fr à très vite
alors là je m'arrête là dessus parce que
c'est très marrant qu'est-ce qu'on peut
voir dans le verbal déjà dans le verbal
on voit que j'ai pas dit à très bientôt
ciao mais j'ai dit à très vite salut
c'est une blague une petite blagounette
dans le non verbal voilà on peut voir
dans la posture là je vous en prie
asseyez-vous
on dit souvent qu'une image vaut mieux
que mille mots c'est interrogatoire va
être très
muscler vous pouvez me dire où vous
étiez en janvier vers 20h début janvier
vers 20h j'étais où j'étais du Kato 8
j'étais à Nantes à la compagnie du café
théâtre il y a quelqu'un qui peut
corroborer les faits un peu ouais mon
petit bonhomme parce que c'était complet
c'est un théâtre
non je veux dire le spectacle ça tient
ah il tient pas mal ça va
création tous les soirs sont différents
mais ça commence à avoir une structure
c'est mais c'est quoi l'objet de votre
recherche je ne sais plus du tout
pourquoi je vous interrogeais peut-être
que c'est pour répondre à la fameuse
question qu'on me pose toujours à la fin
des spectacles quand je parle avec le
public qu'elle était là il est pas là
Loïc peut-être que je serai là mais pour
vous surveiller et salut et bienvenue
dans la partie sponsoria c'est
sponsoris
fusion des deux depuis quelques temps on
essaie de rendre ce moment un peu fun et
pétillant et drôle aussi
c'était du champagne pour le petit selon
l'adage grandir c'est apprendre de ses
erreurs quand je suis né je faisais 52
cm un grand bébé et je me présente
aujourd'hui devant vous 134 cm plus tard
c'est dire à quel point j'ai commis des
erreurs non mais là vous devez vous dire
ouais mais Loïc tu vas en euros
exactement avec cette histoire de
centimètres et ben justement je vais
vous dire non mais parce que c'est
important je voulais revenir sur un
mythe autour de la taille de la je
m'arrête juste là parce que je sens que
je vais prendre encore quelques
centimètres si je continue alors non je
pense que je voulais dire la taille du
de la de votre niveau de fun vous en
avez assez d'avoir un tout petit niveau
de fun on se moque de votre niveau de
fin de tout petit il est tout mignon son
niveau de fan vous voulez un niveau de
fun bien épais et ben j'ai la solution
pour vous en création de Fabien olicard
salut c'est Fabien en fait je suis
désolé de vous le dire mais il y aura
pas de sponsorias cette fois c'est la
première fois que ça arrive dans
l'histoire des matières grises mais là
je peux pas et c'est dommage parce qu'on
avait fait un petit scénario incroyable
avec Loïc on était parti filmer Londres
et en haut de Big Ben on avait prévu un
sosie de Sherlock Holmes qui était en
train de dire mon magazine vous avez
curieuse et ça ça devait vous rappeler
que le prochain numéro allait sortir on
faisait un lien de dingue parce que ta
Sherlocks qui se retourner face caméra
et qui disait moi aussi j'ai failli
oublier de m'abonner mais heureusement
Watson m'a offert ça il a bam Charlotte
qui montre mon dernier livre il
approchait de l'écran tout près tout
près de l'écran tu vois et plus que le
livre et hop gros des hommes et on se
retrouve dans les rues de New York alors
il y a pas trop de liens avec New York
mais c'est un peu stylé quand même New
York voilà et là tu as un mec qui danse
dans la rue il a les claquer des doigts
et au moment précis où tu l'acte des
doigts et ben BIM il faisait nuit dans
New York et on voyait mon livre mon sur
les écrans de Time Square bonjour
monsieur Gaston du Comptoir des bonnes
affaires et justement aujourd'hui j'ai
une bonne affaire pour vous pour
ressembler beaucoup
vous voyez ce livre normalement il est à
100000 euros c'est très très mais
aujourd'hui pour vous une offre
exceptionnelle 30 000 € c'est vraiment
pour un livre c'est waouh qui avait
juste là aujourd'hui ce livre que je
vous propose est à 7,95 c'est une offre
qui dure 5 minutes je connais cette
technique en fait c'est le Fomo c'est
avec cette offre exceptionnelle et ce
livre je rajoute un cadeau en rupture de
sol d'une valeur de 418 euros c'est un
bisou sur un pont monsieur un bisou sur
le front très cher comme comme truc
c'est un bisou en plus de ce bisou sur
le front une piscine une piscine de
valeur de 18 € monsieur
pas très cher c'est une piscine
on met de l'eau et elle
et Monsieur
bonsoir le palais de glace merci
beaucoup d'être venu si
vous étiez pas venu ce serait vachement
moins bien ce spectacle s'appelle
archétype quelle est votre prénom
ragondin ragondin
ici dans ma veste j'ai une enveloppe en
fait dans le spectacle dans ma base j'ai
une enveloppe ici pensez à quelque chose
ok c'est bon à quoi vous pensez à
quelque chose à quelque chose à quelque
chose je prends le truc l'englobe
j'ouvre et là il y a marqué quelque
chose mais non
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup d'être venu à ce
spectacle par les gens autour de vous
ces spectacle de
la salle ah d'accord laissez des
critiques sur les sites de billetterie
si vous avez aimé je m'appelle Fabien
olicard et si vous avez pas aimé je
m'appelle Victor Vincent
je vous aime bientôt à très très fort
ciao
moi j'ai été bluffé par ce spectacle et
puis cette salle le Palais des Glaces ah
il est retour
[Musique]